enfin chassé pas compliqué sébastien les
savants de feutre il ne lui en reste
plus que 32 combien gens lui en a pris
mais non du coup tu réfléchis pour
comines
l'ol s'est fait chopé au lycée entre
12h06 balance toi quoi pénis musique
cette histoire encore
alors
merci alors
[Musique]
vous rendez pas compte en fait partie
qu'est-ce que je lançais on a transféré
nos esprits dans le corps de quelqu'un
d'autre
[Musique]
mais c'est immonde non non non rolland
team n'avait pas son permis bateau selon
tueurs l'ont fait les amis confiante
[Musique]
c'est juste à rétro ça va
donc c'est qu'il ya reboisement genre
[Musique]
vous inquiétez pas il ya quand même
quelque chose qui cloche non chauffés
si tu veux que ça reste sexuelle ça
restera
on l'a fait combien de fois 37
tu fais aussi de passe
elle avait des seringues sur elle ça
c'est normal ce salon est un chien sait
pas où sa mère 6 6 6 à 8
[Musique]